if you were going to pitch this film and
kind of like a solo synchronized
swimming fashion
how would you pitch it rain moves some
hair flip some pelvic thrusts just
pretend like azomite right and just move
it around everywhere with me
joshing sin haste and today it's gonna
get wet it's gonna get wild it's Aquaman
you are an actual Queen in this in my
opinion you're so great but what would
be your real life directly name I sense
you've got so much sass you would serve
that ah I feel like Emma directly I just
wanted to pin up in the wrong packaging
unfortunately because it's just as far
to neutral for my taste her up to me
every day would be a with me a moment
what was your wet and wild song be
though that's like the best question
ever thank you very much no worry um I
think I would go I'm a lean towards
Elton John which wall the Mona Lisa's
among Hatter's but then also I want to
be more festive and do some ice girls oh
my god yes no slam it to the left you
having a good time shakes to the right
oh man and also what I loved about this
is the hair flipping I feel like you
could teach a degree in hair flipping
after this actually like you're like Shh
Jason is far more and better mmm
honestly that's coming from me and I
like to think of myself as a as a pro
hair flipper I mean but Jason takes the
cake no I mean I have to I have to give
it to him what are your top tips for
hair flipping like with that old head
back I think I feel like you taught him
a lot about cleavage goals
he's also got me be probably there if
the Train is you know you there he would
work out in between takes that's long
time we could find time to work out is
when they say cut I'm going home on it
Aquaman does like to get on air she's
done for an employer the characters what
would the ultimate night out with you be
like well
last night we went to a mascara Artie
and then just started dancing around
how are you at the dancing well I'm wine
so we invented the hula so you get the
hula why do I just swing my hips with
this what I loved about it is it's kind
of like a flawed masculine character as
well it was that important to bring out
a softer edge to masculinity through
this film which is saying take this
important period you know I was raised
by women I was visiting my grandmother
my mom I think that's kind of I mean
it's absolutely important not to know
yourself to to be able to get to those
sensitive moments to open up instead of
being this macho I think that's very
important you know the part where he's
he's doing it for his family and his
friends it's a hard part to like crack
through and go just family okay so I
think I can relate to that and probably
what helped play the character
[Music]